журналісти продовжують примати по грозі
віру святі ціна patek погрози журналісти
радіо волі на сюди на підлогу та по грози
катерина circa швидкої зуб і
і грамоті когось продовжу вигляду вата і
ножами
я не бачу як я мазала хитайся в ряді мвс
нічого пірнув радіо свобода ви на вила
у піхву
ми не будемо його на шановного ціна
тому гулянку джанні у журналістки
діяльності
явно сказав htc конфлікт прямо у цьому
міністерство внутрішніх страх просто е а
крім політики та акіно ближче не до
міністерства внутрішніх справ якісь
стильно про мутузити миротворець я не
знають об'єктивних вигляд але самі 7
миротворцем соску вирішить роберт бета
україна журналістські розслідування та
зміни так вищі у конфлікт